this is a production of Cornell
University
hi
um thank you Anna for the introduction
and um thank you all for staying a bit
past time to listen to my talk
um I'm excited to share current progress
on this project to integrate multimodal
proximal remote sensing data for
improved predictions of agronomically
important crop traits
so um mailing gave a very nice
introduction to high throughput
phenotyping and and my why we might want
to deploy this
um
and because of those advantages the
implementation and variety of either put
sensors and platforms has increased in
in recent years
um and as prohibitive costs go down and
additional sensors are developed this
trend is likely to continue so with this
comes the need to analyze large amounts
of new and often complex and high
dimensional data
so here I'm going to focus on two such
sensors and platforms the first is a
multi-spectral camera which has been
deployed on unoccupied aerial Vehicles
so the Drone picture there
the camera that we are using uh captures
five different bands and allows us to
capture information on a canopy level
spectral information
the second is a lidar camera deployed on
unoccupied ground Vehicles so the little
ground Rover car Robot and the photo
there
lidar scans yield
3D reconstructions of entire plots and
in this way allow us to capture
subcanopy architectural information
so
multi-spectral images are typically used
to calculate vegetation indices
lidar scans which are used to generate
Point clouds are used to extract plant
height and stem width as two common
examples
[Music]
um
but uh despite the fact that these
sensors capture unique spatial and
structural information they are often
used separately
um so our goal here is to integrate the
UAV multi-spectral images with the ugv
lidar point clouds
um
and we aim to do this by using machine
learning methods to extract latent
phenotypes these Lane phenotypes will be
used to then predict
phenotypes of interests such as grain
yield
so we're doing this for the data
collected through the genomes to Fields
project to collect stata for maize
hybrids up at Musgrave research Farm in
Aurora
and we have Rover and drone data
collected over the past five years
so a little bit more background the
Rover here has a typical RGB cameras and
then the lidar camera is on the back of
the Rover here these are two row plots
so we drive the Rover in between those
two rows
and in the resulting Point clouds
um pictured in the these two images here
you can see
um the row on the left and the row on
the right now these Point clouds
are also capturing points in adjacent
Lots so ultimately we crop those to
generate this final Point Cloud here
um each point in the point Cloud
contains an x y and a z coordinate
giving the positional
um relative position of that point to
the Rover
this cropped Point Cloud here still has
about 250
000 points in it
the multi-spectral camera is deployed on
the bottom of the Drone here and an
example of a single plot level image is
shown on the right
this image has been printed separately
for each band for visualization you can
think of the resulting image as a stack
of all five of these
so as the uh drone flies over the field
it takes images at fixed points these
raw images have about 80 percent overlap
in order to Overlay them we use a
software called pix4d to generate this
final Ortho mosaic
image to then split the orthomosaic up
by plot we use
image free just developed by Nick
Morales in the Robin's lab and that
allows us to draw bounding boxes around
each of the plots and ultimately arrive
at these plot level images
so now that we have plot level images
and plot level Point clouds how do we
actually extract these latent phenotypes
so we started with the multi-spectral
images and trained what is called an
auto encoder model
so an autoencoder is an unsupervised
machine learning model
which takes the original images passes
them through a neural network to produce
the latent codes
Z
the latent phenotypes the latent codes
are then passed through a second neural
network the decoder to reproduce the
original image and this model is
optimized such that the difference
between the Reconstruction and the
original image is minimized
once the model is trained we can then
pass all images through the encoder and
extract these latent codes
so you can think of an auto encoder
model similar to principal component
analysis we are performing
dimensionality reduction here
learning these latent representations
removing noise
but in contrast to
ndvi or plant height we're allowing
the machine to learn the important
features
in this context we start from original
images that are five band
396 pixels tall and 94 pixels wide it's
about 185 000 values and reducing them
to a vector of length 256.
so this shows results from an initial
test to overfit on a single
multi-spectral image and see if we could
fully reconstruct the original image
from latent codes
from there we scaled up to training on
10 different dates so about 5000
multi-spectral images
from the g2f fields in 2020
and you can see that though the
Reconstruction from the test set is
Warrior
the model is still able to nearly
reconstruct the original image
so now we've shown that the latent
vectors are inefficient representation
and capture the relevant
and necessary information to reconstruct
the original images so the next thing
that we wanted to do was start
investigating these latent phenotypes to
see what kinds of information was
contained within them
so we started by doing a PCA on the
latent vectors so this is for all 5000
images and colored them by days after
planting here and in DVI over here and
we do see clustering
in both of these
um so
the next thing that we did is to take
the first 25 of those principal
components which explain about 45 of the
total variation
and we performed linear regression to
predict the ndbi values from those
principal components so in this um
figure here we have the actual ndvi
values on the x-axis and the predicted
in DVI values on the y-axis and the
correlation between those was 0.89
so this tells us that not only are the
latent codes reduced representations of
the multi-spectral images they also
contain biologically relevant
information
so our next steps are to further
investigate those latent phenotypes
um
develop and Implement a second model for
the point clouds
and we're looking into potential model
architectures currently
and then ultimately
we will extract latent codes from both
the multi-spectral images and the point
clouds to predict
are phenotypes of Interest
um so I'd like to thank my committee
members
um Liam and folks from the buckler lab
for collecting this data as well as Abe
Davis Peter Michael and Joe Gage for
their assistance and Guidance with
implementing this model
and um I'm happy to take questions this
time thank you so much
[Music]
um
yes um so
uh we did some classification and
regression tasks on the latent codes
initially
um we don't see too much improved
performance but it also doesn't reduce
their performance so similar to taking
from the principal components taking all
256 of those for example
um increasing that number doesn't tend
to increase the the performance
um
um so I'm not familiar with the ground
radar but on those days of where you do
imaging can you is it possible to use
like calibration images to maybe reduce
the error or can you just infer that
from the images themselves on the the
lidar point pads
um
yeah so that's a that's a good question
yeah so we have the calibration panels
uh to account for lighting and things
like that with multi-spectral images
um there's
um not an analogous kind of calibration
metric
um so uh concerns with that whereas like
lighting might be a concern for
multi-spectral images you'll have some
kind of random variation for wind
um things like that as you're driving
through on different days or at
different times
um so uh hopefully I think the goal is
that the the auto encoder model will be
able to kind of parse out that noise
[Music]
no so yeah at this point
um so the question was if the ground
Rover can calculate humidity or can it
be temperature
um so the only information that we're
gaining from the point clouds is the
positional information
okay great thank you all so much
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu